[Música]
El Congreso de Perú rechaza por tercera
vez la posibilidad de adelantar las
elecciones que ha sido un pedido tanto
del gobierno de Dina boluarte como de
los manifestantes antigubernamentales
así los comicios se sostienen por el
momento para 2026 y no serán en julio de
2023 como planteaba la iniciativa
conectaremos con lima
los republicanos de Estados Unidos le
ganan una batalla a los demócratas en la
cámara baja pues lograron la mayoría
para expulsar del comité de asuntos
exteriores a la representante Ilan Omar
sostienen que fue por seis comentarios
que hizo contra Israel pero los
demócratas alegan que fue una venganza
por una destitución similar de dos
republicanos en 2021
España y Marruecos firmaron un memorando
sobre la cooperación agroalimentaria y
sanitaria Ese fue uno de los logros de
la décima segunda reunión de alto nivel
entre los dos países y también pactaron
abrir la aduana en ceuta y trataron el
tema del Sahara occidental que
históricamente los ha distanciado
ampliamos desde rabat
buenas noches y bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 los saluda María
Clara calle iniciamos en Perú con la
noticia de último momento el congreso
rechazó el proyecto de ley que promovió
el partido izquierdista Perú libre para
adelantar las elecciones generales a
Julio de 2023 y además realizar una
consulta sobre si hacer o no una
asamblea Constituyente Esta es la
segunda propuesta que hunda en los
legisladores en una semana después de
votar negativamente en dos ocasiones un
proyecto anterior que pretendía
establecer la fecha de las elecciones
para diciembre de 2023 vamos en vivo a
Lima donde estaba nuestro corresponsal
Francisco Zacarías Francisco Buenas
noches y cuéntenos por qué se hundió
este nuevo proyecto Y qué ocurrió en el
congreso
Buenas noches en realidad siempre ha
sido lo que se venía diciendo que el
proyecto que imponía el
representante de la izquierda
que estaba en minoría poniendo la
proyección de la solicitud de todas las
marchas era que la asamblea
Constituyente debería
convocarse dentro del adelanto de
elecciones las bancadas de derecha se
opusieron esto era el principal escollo
que se señalaba para la aprobación y fue
la discusión Porque muchos congresistas
decían que era anticonstitucional tratar
de poner en el adelanto de elecciones y
que también se impusiera en la agenda la
convocatoria una asamblea Constituyente
y por el otro lado los congresistas de
izquierda decían Bueno si nosotros
estábamos poniendo eso también el
proyecto de la derecha tenía como
escondido la reelección de los
legisladores porque mencionaba que
podían postular a
los cargos que ellos tendrían que dejar
entonces así las cosas no hubo el apoyo
que necesitaba el congresista quito el
que era portavoz de esta propuesta en
minoría Nosotros hemos estado siguiendo
de cerca las reacciones que se
produjeron en Lima en las marchas de
protesta precisamente nos dijeron que
esta situación para ellos les da mucha
más intriga sobre Qué es el trasfondo de
lo que puede estar pasando y también
anunciaron que van a seguir protestando
en el interior del Perú y también en
Lima por lo que ellos están viendo que
el congreso no le interesa realizar el
adelanto de elecciones tal como lo piden
ellos y también como lo ha solicitado la
presidenta Dina boluarte y con este
panorama en el legislativo Qué opciones
Le quedan al gobierno para lograr
adelantar las elecciones
Bueno al gobierno de Dina boluarte le
queda la única salida de insistir con el
proyecto que ha presentado el Primer
Ministro Alberto tarola al parlamento
peruano precisamente la comisión de
Constitución ha citado al Primer
Ministro peruano a que acuda el día que
ha sido citado que va a ser dentro de
unas horas se va a abrir este caso en la
comisión del congreso para que el Primer
Ministro detalle Cuál es el alcance en
sí de la iniciativa pero muchos
analistas están diciendo que eso va a
ser un alargue porque la comisión de
Constitución va a tener luego que
debatir la aprobarla y enviarla a la
comisión permanente esta Va a ser el
mismo proceso para enviarla al pleno del
parlamento peruano y someter la votación
muchos están vaticinando que el
parlamento no va a aprobar esto y al
gobierno de boluarte le va a quedar
enviar al Primer Ministro a hacer
cuestión de confianza para que se
apruebe la Bueno ya veremos entonces
Francisco cómo se soluciona este
problema allí en Perú y nosotros
continuamos con noticias de Estados
Unidos porque fue expulsada de la
comisión de asuntos exteriores de la
cámara de representantes ylan Omar por
218 votos a favor de la expulsión y 211
en contra la bancada republicana se
impuso y achacaron discutibles
comentarios antisemitas pero los
demócratas ven la decisión como una
forma de vengar las expulsiones
republicanas que hubo en 2021
los republicanos se hacen notar en la
cámara de representantes y este martes
hicieron valer su mayoría para expulsar
a la demócrata y la nahumar de la
comisión de asuntos exteriores de la
cámara
para ser claros una representante puede
decir lo que quiera pero no tenemos que
aceptarlo las personas que tienen
opiniones tan odiosas deberían ser
excluidas de este tipo de comités
los republicanos achacan a Omar seis
declaraciones especialmente un tuit de
2019 que un mar borró y por el que
después se disculpó el tuit decía que
todo se trata de los benjamins una
referencia al billete de 100 dólares de
Benjamin Franklin con el que insinuaba
que Los partidarios de Israel Solo
piensan en el dinero Omar se defendió
no en el congreso para guardar silencio
vine el congreso para hacer su voz y mi
liderazgo y mi voz No disminuirán si no
estoy en este comité por un periodo mi
voz será más y más fuerte y mi liderazgo
será celebrado en todo el mundo como lo
ha sido
la expulsión se suma a la negativa del
líder de la mayoría republicana Kevin
mccarthy a que los demócratas Erick y
Adam shift hagan parte de la comisión de
inteligencia decisiones vistas como
retaliaciones por las expulsiones de los
republicanos Marjorie Taylor Green y
Paul gozar en 2021 cuando los demócratas
tenían mayoría por retórica incendiaria
los compañeros de Omar salieron en su
defensa
colegas me presento ante ustedes como
una orgullosa judía y una orgullosa
amiga y colega de Ilan Omar
Omar llegó a Estados Unidos como
refugiada desde somalia es la única
congresista nacida en África y una de
las pocas mujeres musulmanas de la
cámara de representantes forma parte de
los nueve representantes demócratas
conocidos Como de squat por su carácter
progresista y por su juventud
en Ecuador ya comenzaron las votaciones
de las elecciones seccionales las del
Consejo de participación ciudadana y las
de ocho reformas constitucionales que
promueve el gobierno de Guillermo lasso
aunque los comicios son El domingo 5 de
febrero casi 5.500 presos podían votar
hoy en 35 cárceles del país y ellos
podrían hacerlo pues aún no tienen una
sentencia en contra las urnas estarán
selladas hasta el conteo general del
domingo y por otra parte la consulta
popular que impulsa El Ejecutivo consta
de ocho preguntas sobre la extradición
La regulación a la fiscalía la reducción
del número de congresistas y también la
limitación de nuevos movimientos
políticos y el cuidado ambiental entre
otros temas
seguimos en nuestra región porque en
Brasil un congresista estaba acusando el
expresidente Jair bolsonaro de gestar un
plan para evitar que Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva se posesionara el primero de
enero de 2023 El senador de Centro
izquierda Marcos Duval afirma que en
diciembre del año pasado se reunió con
bolsonaro y también con el diputado
Daniel silveira segundo aval le pidieron
que grabara ilegalmente al presidente
del tribunal superior electoral
Alexandre de moraesh y hacerlo caer en
una contradicción de esa manera
lograrían que demorara arrestado y así
Lula no podría tomar posesión los
mensajes los publicó la revista bella de
Brasil sin embargo Nopal se contradice
por ejemplo cuando menciona el lugar
donde ocurrió la reunión y al decir si
bolsonaro lo instó directamente al golpe
o solo escuchó el plan
la idea era que colocaran el equipo de
grabación habría un vehículo cerca del
tribunal supremo grabando el audio y yo
en esta reunión con el ministro
Alexandre lo llevaría a decir que en
algunos de los procesos traspasó la
línea de la Constitución y de inmediato
dije que no haría eso no haría ese tipo
de cosas y le dije mire presidente y
Daniel esto es ilegal para hacer esta
grabación Ustedes deben tener
autorización del juez
las altas temperaturas en Chile están
provocando múltiples incendios
forestales el más grave de ellos es el
que comenzó el miércoles en la región de
ñuble las llamas ya han consumido más de
700 hectáreas según el centro de
prevención y atención de desastres de
chile y afectado a las comunas de
chillán chillán viejo y kirihue que
fueron declaradas en alerta roja allí el
fuego destruyó seis casas también el
centro de prevención registra incendios
más al sur en la región de bío bío en la
comuna de los Ángeles las temperaturas
rondan los 40 grados celsius y los
vientos secos han llegado desde la Pampa
Argentina
cambiamos de noticia porque finalizó en
rabat la décimo segunda reunión de alto
nivel entre Marruecos y España ambos
países acordaron allí la apertura de la
aduana en ceuta un acuerdo pesquero y
también de cooperación agrícola además
trataron el tema del Sahara occidental
que históricamente ha distanciado a los
dos países Marina Colorado nuestra
enviada especial a Marruecos nos da más
detalles de las conclusiones
con el cierre de esta reunión de alto
nivel en rabat Marruecos y España
esperan empezar una nueva etapa en su
relación diplomática basada en la
comunicación constante la transparencia
y así dejar atrás las acciones
unilaterales del pasado como fórmula
para conseguir resultados políticos los
presidentes del gobierno marroquí y
españolas isaacruz y Pedro Sánchez
firmaron una veintena de tratados sobre
energías renovables pesca migración o
Comercio en este sentido se habló de la
normalización progresiva del paso de
personas y mercancías por tierra y mar
sin embargo no se hace mención explícita
a ceuta y melilla únicos territorios
españoles y por lo tanto europeos con
frontera terrestre al continente
africano y sobre los que Marruecos
históricamente ha reclamado su soberanía
Y es que precisamente Pedro Sánchez
anunció que ambos eludirán a hablar de
temas que puedan ofender al otro sobre
todo en temas territoriales Eso sí se
mencionó de nuevo el agradecimiento por
parte de rabat a Pedro Sánchez por
apoyar la solución de auto que propone
Marruecos al conflicto del Sáhara
occidental por su lado el jefe de
gobierno marroquí insistió en la
importancia de estrechar lazos con
España para abrirse así al mercado
latinoamericano así como a la Unión
Europea porque recordemos que España
ostentará la presidencia rotatoria del
Consejo del bloque comunitario a partir
de julio de este año
el Primer Ministro de Israel Benjamín
llegó a París allí fue recibido en el
Palacio del Elíseo por el presidente
francés Emmanuel bajó el tema principal
de su encuentro giró en torno al
programa nuclear en Irán por lo que
Israel Busca aliados a nivel
internacional para conformar una
coalición militar con las potencias
occidentales que apoyen sus ambiciones
contra Teherán y parece que sus
intenciones van por buen camino pues al
término de la reunión denunció lo que
llamó un avance precipitado del programa
nuclear iraní
y este jueves Rusia conmemoró los 80
años de la Batalla de stalingrado
considerada como la más mortífera en la
historia de la humanidad la ciudad
stalingrado ahora llamada Volvo grado
supuso un punto de inflexión en la
Segunda Guerra Mundial pues hasta ese
momento la maquinaria del ejército nazi
había arrasado con todos sus rivales
pero la victoria del ejército ruso en la
ciudad de stalin a principios de 1943
marcó el principio del fin para la
Alemania de Hitler
stalingrado Unión soviética 31 de enero
de 1943 friedrich paulus comandante del
sexto ejército alemán se rinde tras
meses de guerra en un cruento invierno
meses antes en medio de la operación
barbarroja adolf Hitler ordena dividir
las tropas que buscaban tomar el caucaso
al sur de Rusia para conquistar la
estratégica ciudad de stalingrado
con la toma de la ciudad stalin la
Alemania nazi buscaba un golpe simbólico
y moral en medio de una ciudad destruida
por los bombardeos de la Luke bafen la
fuerza aérea alemana el campo de guerra
se vuelve un territorio óptimo para los
francotiradores y la lucha caza a casa a
finales de 1942 los nazis controlan casi
la totalidad de la ciudad y el destino
de la urbe parece definido sin embargo
en secreto la unión soviética estaba
acumulando cerca de un millón de
combatientes Al Otro Lado Del Río volga
en lo que se denominó operación ural
tras la ofensiva soviética a principios
de 1943 más de 300.000 soldados alemanes
habían quedado atrapados gracias al
movimiento de pinza del ejército rojo a
finales de enero el esfuerzo alemán por
abastecer las tropas rodeadas resulta
infructuoso los soviéticos capturan
90.000 soldados nazis
finalmente el 2 de febrero de 1943 los
combates cesan y una de las batallas más
importantes de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
llega su fin dejando más de 2 millones
300.000 personas muertas
800.000 combatientes del bando alemán y
cerca de un millón y medio en tres
soldados y civiles soviéticos
[Música]
así llegamos al final de las noticias
sigan en France 24
[Música]